um last week unfortunately and this
really is tragic
last week may actually not be the
craziest week of donald trump's
presidency it may be
uh this week and what is effectively the
last eight or nine days of donald
trump's presidency leading up to when
next wednesday's swearing in of
president joe biden um
there are new reports out about donald
trump's plans for this week
and it appears as though it is going to
be
an absolutely insane week
from donald trump donald trump of course
now suspended permanently
from twitter as we will talk about in a
little bit
uh donald trump after denouncing his own
vice president last wednesday at least
as of last night
hasn't even spoken to mike pence
and he is considering what can he
do in this last week and every
possibility
is completely bonkers remember that
discussion
about a possible pardon in advance a
blanket pardon in advance of his own
family members it is increasingly
looking like donald trump is going to do
that in the next eight or nine days
maybe by the time you listen to this
clip some of those pardons
will already have started there is still
the con consideration of donald trump
pardoning himself in fact and i know
that every time i talk about this people
right i didn't say a president cannot
pardon themselves
remember that we've gone into the
legality the legal scholarship on this
there are divergent opinions as to
whether a president can or cannot pardon
themselves but the most
important thing is it had no it has not
been tested in court ever
and it is certainly possible that a
president can pardon themselves and
there is that
possibility as well trump absolutely
furious with twitter and other social
media
platforms for banning him either uh
temporarily
indefinitely or for life up to and
including twitter which we will talk
about
there is the idea that donald trump is
looking to do
something to big tech over the next uh
eight days that he has left nine days
that he has left in office
we don't know exactly what that will be
but it very well may be
maybe absolutely out of this world and
then donald trump
also reportedly planning to go to the
border
in alamo texas in in principle tomorrow
tuesday to make a big deal i guess
out of his major success of building the
wall i
not that at this point i need to remind
you but
this is yet another broken promise
fortunately it's a broken promise
because it was going to be a waste of
time and money to begin with
but donald trump promised that by the
end of his first term
we would have a wall between the u.s
mexico border on the u.s mexico border
across the entire border and of course
what we've seen
are modest improvements to a few and and
i'm using the term improvements
in terms of what they are called from a
construction standpoint um
modest improvements or renovations to a
few hundred miles of wall and that is
actually something donald trump has
promised and failed mexico didn't pay
for it trump didn't build the wall but
it's sort of a last
salvo he started by coming down the
escalator and telling us mexico's not
sending their best they're sending
uh the criminals and etc um and it looks
like we are sort of coming full circle
with donald trump
flying down to texas reportedly tomorrow
to claim
that he delivered on that that promise
as well
so there there are a number of different
um
what what to call there are a lot of
really bad arguments being made about
what should or shouldn't happen over
the next week and of course as we read
about the insane week that donald trump
has planned
my mind immediately goes to of course he
should be removed immediately by the
25th amendment but that requires
the cabinet and mike pence to act every
indication so far
as we mentioned earlier is mike pence is
not interested in doing that
so then you have to realize
that uh impeachment must happen
impeachment must happen
and the fact that we are seeing some
right wingers saying it would be too
divisive
there are some on the right and left
saying impeaching or removing trump
would make him a martyr
he's already both a deity and a martyr
uh to his own people the the committed
trumpist
sees trump almost like a god who can do
no wrong and say no wrong
and they already believe him to be a
martyr because as far as they see he's
been treated so unfairly by the
supposed fake news media he's been
treated so unfairly by the democrats and
all of this stuff
they are crazy and violent already they
are already
attacking violently as we saw last week
because trump lost the election and
neither he nor they can come to grips
with reality so
as i said earlier if removal is
warranted you must remove
if impeachment is warranted you must
impeach uh it doesn't appear as though
removal will happen so it must be
impeachment and as i said before taking
swift legal action against donald trump
and the insurrectionist riot riotous
terrorists
and every state and local republican
member
who supported this that is the best way
to stop this movement
the idea of it would be divisive to
impeach again that doesn't stop the
movement my friends that's a failure
it's nothing it's not
it's not actually anything trump should
already be gone
and that's why i support another
impeachment which
uh we we discussed earlier waiting even
one more day
could spell disaster look at the
insanity of what he's planning over the
next week and then consider the urgency
of what's going on
when you see me sitting here at the
microphone oftentimes i'm wearing
a shirt by a company called teddy
stratford and i love these shirts so
much that i
asked teddy stratford to be a sponsor of
the show
and here's why i like their shirt so
much with other slim fit button up
shirts
you often get this weird-looking gap
between the buttons where it looks kind
of stretched out but teddy stratford
actually has a patented zipper
that's hidden underneath the buttons
which secures the shirt against your
chest so it doesn't look
stretched and most importantly it just
provides a nicer looking fit overall
and the entire shirt is specially
designed to really
improve the way your upper body looks
when you're wearing it it also has a
special type of collar
that prevents it from drooping down and
spreading open which is another
really great thing about these shirts
all of these things
really do a lot to make a big difference
when you're looking at a shirt
and that's why i like to wear teddy
stratford shirts on the show
go check them out at davidpakman.com
teddy the link is down below and they'll
give you 15
off your first order if you use the
coupon code pacman at checkout